so today's topic well according to
singer Rihanna
it depends what they're crying about
Rihanna posted this meet instead said if
we get together and your ex died and you
cry you think
could you imagine somebody said [ __ ] and
you start weeping I'm sorry I think that
there is a time and place for everything
I think if you have such uncontrollable
emotion when it comes to that person
that you can't even control it to not do
it in front of your current spouse that
you might still have some type of
feelings for that person 100,000% I
agree so so you so okay hold on
you want no hold on
so do you want
[Music]
so do you also what to be vulnerable or
someone that controls their emotions
control the fact that they are crying
over someone they potentially loved over
someone that they had kids with over
someone that they shared intimacy with
and that this person is no longer going
to be alive and if I cry if I show that
I care deeply about this person I'm
single so this is what I mean I say be
careful who you fall for
because a lot of people claim they love
but in reality what they want is
ownership what they want is a trophy
they want someone that they can say that
they're with so that their friends and
family like oh you with somebody and
they can get that love and affection but
they're not really capable in our last
video we talked about possessiveness in
relationship yeah and we were thinking
eyes how a lot of people don't recognize
how possessors they're being this was
she presented to you it's level 99
positional / yes / cuz the person is
dead is dead if you buy for Christmas a
Ouija board and even then you have to
open that [ __ ] and play it because it's
a two to five people game good to eat
clear and you get two to five people to
help you cheat with a Ouija board you
kind of deserve to be able to cheat Oh
imagine if you're like using the Ouija
board with you your [ __ ] and then your
girl walks in your back oh so you won't
just cheat on me with this ghost [ __ ]
she's probably sucking your bit right
now is you as you are is you all right
where you at [ __ ] who you gonna call ho
Buster's afraid of no hope
with this relationship apparently you're
only bound to this area so your spirit
could be free and my spirit could be
free you know what I mean
I mean I know this is a situation shape
but I'm not ready for a ghost racing
[ __ ] that's the one say goodbye ghost
babe you know I think it's interesting
that she said that you know it's
disrespectful to cry in front of her
about a dead ex the irony is that if I
had never dated that person I may never
have become the man that you're seeing
today that you are in a relationship
with now that [ __ ] happened in my couple
what do you mean well when when when one
of my girl bought my girls one of my
girls ex died hmm he commit a suicide
hmm she went to the funeral rolled
everything like a boy she learned about
that she was crying oh my oh [ __ ] and I
knew the dude yeah I didn't like to do
nothing
oh she was hurt yeah no what did you
feel my it doesn't matter what I feel my
girls hurt yeah but he regrets that what
she was feeling what was your response I
don't want my girl to be hurt every best
really generally what it was like not
because I'm a better person than anybody
but it's just the way maybe it's the way
I was raised some [ __ ] like that you
know [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up to take your own life
it's really crazy
can you imagine crying over someone that
the job that ends there Johnny
yes I can yeah the only thing like you
do was be there when she wanted and give
her space when she needed a space she
went to the funeral rooms like she's
like my girl was like do you mind if I
go if you don't like no she go I have
friends that I'm no longer friends with
that I haven't been friends with for 10
15 years either cuz we grew apart and
all that but those people were a big
part yeah I lived experience I mean I
was spending every single day with these
people and then after a while it just
kind of fizzled out because of a
difference effective but if I were to
find out today that my childhood friends
just died randomly it would bring me a
whole bunch of sadness back and they
were necessary for me to get to where I
am too
I just hope that they get to get to
where they need to go to be happy that's
it I'm not even trying to sit I'm a
better person than whenever whatever but
it's just yet how was raised it's just
like can we put this can I just say
though you you are a better person
because anybody who can put themselves
aside for other people suffering is
inherently better for Humanity because
they're putting others above themselves
that's what I hope I get to instill in
my kids into and my friends in my
community the idea of sacrificing for
others and he didn't put his personal
feelings about the dude first would he
put her on put above anything else is
his girl suffering oh boy and I didn't
like that boy and he didn't like me
either all right
I was yeah I was the meaning that's all
no new friends no no no I get you guys
might if you feel it look it's normal it
is currently it's perfectly normal to
feel maybe a little bit of jealousy
maybe a little bit of anger and you
feeling that doesn't inherently make you
a bad person what you feel is not
determining who you are as a human being
how you act however is if you deny
somebody the opportunity to mourn the
death of someone they used to love then
that is where you make a terrible action
right you feeling that you can cast that
aside you can be a bigger person guy hey
let me be here for this person I love
who is suffering right now because
somebody else died that's what makes you
better that that's what proves that
you're not just gonna give in to your
instincts or to your emotion but you're
gonna aspire to something better and so
I just hope you guys take that with you
and you really buy into that because
your emotions aren't the end-all be-all
okay that's all and I could probably
guarantee you that the person who's
suffering who said probably doesn't want
to be they don't want to feel that way
but it inherently is them and it's
overcoming them and they're allowing
themselves to go through that so be
mindful of that
as a man I don't want to be crying over
someone that died but if I'm overcome
with that emotion don't deny me that
expression because it's gonna be a lot
harder for me to trust you and to be
able to share that with you in the
future when it's about something that
you actually are interested in it's like
I have to be
about [ __ ] but this should I have to
suppress out of all the things like
crying if I listen you know if I cry now
cuz big boys don't cry whatever it's
just if I cry I don't wanna cry
but if it happens [ __ ] let it happen
yeah get out the way get out the way but
you want to know how I know she lacks a
lot of empathy cuz if you listen to what
she said she said so you see how all
this is centered around herself her met
her her her husband lost somebody that
he was deal with him right dead and
she's thinking about how she feels once
again it's not so much suffice it's also
the fact that your lack your lack of
self-esteem is at a lowest lowest that's
someone that is bad affects your way of
being threatens you threatens you you
feel threatened that somebody that's
dead boo-boo it's okay you already won
your [ __ ] still warm
and even if he likes hopeless he put ice
in there
[Music]
and this is what makes me really annoyed
with women when it comes to their
speeches on hey man be more vulnerable
hey man have show more emotions you want
us to show emotions wait ve for you why
most men don't actually want to show you
guys emotions because a lot of women are
not worthy of it on one hand you
appreciate the magnitude of our cries
when we do cry meaning we cry we're
father and we cry over our marriage
right cuz you're like oh this is so
amazing he's willing to let me see it
but then when we want to cry over stuff
that we really care about as well you
want to really you want to reduce that
ability but first to do so because what
it makes you feel more secure then it's
not about us showing our emotions it's
about you getting what you want in that
you get to see a part of ourselves that
we don't share to other people you feel
special you want us to show you our
emotions because you know we're Stoics
out there so you want to feel special
when we cry in front of you cause like
we're letting you but have you get that
specially make you feel comfortable
that's why it's [ __ ] it's so much
[ __ ] when people tell us to be more
sensitive and to be more emotionally
open you don't actually want that you
want to add your pistol stairs are just
for me unless you choose to sprinkle the
tears wherever you want I know it's a
bit of look ladies you got to make up
your mind do you guys want us to be
emotional as you don't because if you do
you don't get to put a lid on that you
don't get to tell us when we do get to
cry or when we don't creepy lady
you said I'm naturally creepy because
you are killing the role I got it
as head creep in this duo I would like
to say that I'm quite impressed with
your golem like voice well I learned
from the best
I said that and my hand is on my du
yeah god damn dude there's couple
tissues between anyways tissues how did
you come okay
[Laughter]
[Music]